Let's see if we can work out this function.
Looking again, countdown of n--well, whatever n is, it's going to call countdown with that variable.
It's going to do some statements. It's going to repeat this how many times?
As x is counting down by 5s, it's going to keep doing this until it gets to be 0 or less.
How many times is that going to be?
It's like whatever this x is, which is really whatever this n is,
divided by 5 but rounded up,
because if you have something like 6, x is going to be 6.
It's going to do this loop. X is going to get decremented to 1.
Come back up here--it's still greater than 0.
It's going to do it again.
The only way that it wouldn't have done that if it was exactly 5.
Put 5 in, it executes it once.
Subtract 5 away form it and end up with 0.
It falls through. It doesn't repeat the loop at that point.
What we really want here is to take n divided by 5 and round it up.
This math.ceiling function does that.
It rounds a non-integer number up to the nearest integer.
That's the number of times that these two statements are going to be executed.
We multiply that by 2, and then there's 3 other statements that are going to get executed--
this print statement, this print statement, and this initialization of the y variable.
This formula will actually tell us the number of steps as a function of n that this countdown will do.
What is it? It really is roughly n divided by 5 times 2 plus a constant.
Essentially linear in n. Here's the actual formula.